hello this is Michael Jacoby disz Saddam
Gordon share of entrepreneurship and
innovation at the London Business School
were here at the European summit of the
World Economic Forum and we just
finished a session on clusters
innovation and competitiveness very
interesting discussion on the way in
which in today's environment clusters
may need to adapt and that to a world
were by sectors change and evolve and
competition is between different
ecosystems and architectures so do we
really need clusters in quite the same
way are they good source for public
funds many questions started challenging
the authority and the belief that
classes do make sense and many of the
discussions resulted to an interesting
view in terms of how we should rethink
public policy and what are the most
important parts of innovation that
should be supported by firms and by
governments